mermaids and sirens have often been
linked as the open seas
sultry female seductresses but today I
want to separate their histories and
dive into the unique and important voice
of the siren
the first depictions of sirens were
actually mermaids it all they receive
dwelling monsters with half human half
bird bodies that later change from a
medieval book of monsters claim the
fantastic creatures actually had a scaly
tail but two aspects of the sirens have
always remained the same they live out
at sea and their song is fatal that
voice is what really makes the siren
monster powerful it sound means imminent
danger and often impending death the
stories begin thousands of years ago
during a time when sea travel was
particularly treacherous with accounts
of shipwrecks and drowned sailors
appearing often with seemingly no
explanation the siren was a metaphor for
the dangers at sea where countless
unseen threats lurked under the surface
of the water and above it and we're
being distracted could mean danger and
even death I'm dr. Emily zarqa and
his monstrum the first siren stories
date back to around the 8th century BCE
with Homer's The Odyssey in it Odysseus
and his men prepare to leave the island
of the witch goddess Kirky after year of
post Trojan War debauchery ever the kind
hostess here key warns that they will
encounter two sirens and if the men hear
their beguiling voices they will never
return home turkey does however offer a
suggestion she says that if an men puts
soft wax in their ears they will not be
affected and if Odysseus wants to hear
the delight of the sirens voices he must
have the men tie him to the ship's mast
so he cannot escape the sirens sit in a
flowery meadow on a rocky island
surrounded by a great heap of bones of
moldering men
Odysseus heeds turkeys advice and puts
wax in his men's ears as they near the
island before doing so he tells the man
that Kirky instructed him alone to
listen to the sirens voices he keeps his
own ears unplugged and has his body
bound safely to the mast the sirens hear
the ship as it approaches and in clear
tone songs sing directly to Odysseus
they sing of their knowledge of knowing
all things that come to pass upon the
fruitful earth
Odysseus can't help but be charmed by
the hypnotic voices and he begs to be
removed from the mast but the men bind
him even tighter
they eventually sail past the island and
Odysseus is free from harm notice
something missing there there's no
physical description whatsoever of the
sirens so how do we know what they look
like historical artifacts from
terracotta figurines two vases funerary
pots two perfume bottles and mirror
decorations the siren seems to appear
everywhere in greek art from the 6th
century BCE on early art of the sirens
shows them as part bird and part human
most often with a female head or torso
and clawed feet they commonly have wings
and are always depicted around water in
addition to Greek art written in oral
legends help define the siren
in some versions they refer to as the
Greek River God Akili OSes daughters in
other tales the sirens were the hand
maidens of Persephone who were turned
into winged bird women after witnessing
her abduction by Hades they now spend
their time luring sailors to their
deaths with their song but why have bird
half humans while birds are known for
their song whose melodic or otherwise
but associating birds with death and
water that answer might live thousands
of years earlier with the Egyptian baa
bird ancient Egyptians believed that a
person was made of both physical and
non-physical parts one of these parts
the BA was a representation of a
non-physical part of the person and it
was depicted as a human bird hybrid
after death with a human head bird body
and sometimes human arms the Bob bird
was able to fly from the tomb of the
burial site of the physical corpse but
it always had to return some Egyptian
beliefs also dictated that after
judgment another part of the soul would
need to be rode across the waters of a
lake to reach eternal life since the boz
appearance reflected the sex of the
person
Baal could be male or female which would
explain why some examples of male sirens
exist but usually these sweet tongue
monsters are female while scholars
disagree about when exactly Homer wrote
The Odyssey we do know that the Bob bird
appeared in Egyptian funerary texts
literally hundreds of years before as in
the 15th century BCE there was also
ancient Egyptian art showing the BA as a
human bird hybrid Greeks became frequent
travelers to Egypt around the 6th
century BCE as routes across the
Mediterranean Sea made trade relatively
easier allowing physical goods and ideas
to move between the cultures because of
their near identical appearance and
association with death some scholars
argue that the Egyptian ba bird formed a
foundation of the Greek siren but sirens
aren't exclusive to Greek mythology
the seventh century Spanish scholar in
Archbishop Isidore of Seville wrote in
his ambitious encyclopedia of language
that sirens were said to have had wings
and talons because sexual desire both
flies and wounds they are said to have
lived among the waves because the waves
gave birth to Venus he also writes that
they were harlots who seduced sailors
and other travelers driving them to
destitution which is how he explained
the tales of sailors who died at sea the
original description of the sirens as
bird women may also be explained by
actual carnivorous sea birds that hunt
at sea and whose nests would presumably
be surrounded by the bones and remains
of their kills as time went on medieval
bestiary as depicted sirens frequently
but they are not always described the
same way one example from an earlier
13th century Latin vesti Airy
demonstrates the confusion surrounding
the silenced appearance the three sirens
are all shown with bird wings and feet
and two of them are playing musical
instruments one sirens feet are
different and appear webbed their lower
torsos also appear bird-like to me but I
do think the feathers could also look
like scales to some people especially
that one on the left that could be a
fish tail but hey even she looks
confused
the first siren as a fish woman appears
an art as early as the 7th century CE II
around the same time in the late 70s
early 8th century the publication of the
book of Monsters describes the siren
with the upper torso of a woman and a
scaly tail a few hundred years later is
when we really start to see more sirens
with the tail of a fish in early 13th
century encyclopedic work the author
describes sirens living off the coast of
Britain it reads they have a female head
long shining hair a woman's breasts in
all the limbs of the female form down to
the navel the rest of the body tails off
as a fish with the immense sweetness of
their singing these creatures so
penetrate the hearts of passing sailor
that they succumb utterly to the
sensuous enticement of their ears they
become forgetful of their duty and very
often suffer shipwreck through
carelessness regardless of what they
look like
sirens have always been dangerous in the
14th century
sirens appear in an old Irish variation
of the myth that connects the tempting
women with death explicitly in this
version sailors encountered nine
beautiful women atop a submerged island
at sea the sirens hold the ship for nine
days before giving the men a huge amount
of gold but only after the sailors
promise to return seven years pass and
as the ship's sail past again they try
to avoid the sirens just as they think
they've made it safely away they find
themselves being chased by the sea women
singing a song of lamentation one siren
kills a child she conceived during her
initial encounter with the men and
throws the corpse at the horror stricken
father brutal mermaids have a history
all of their own and I think it's
important to recognize that the legacy
of the seductive siren and her
dangerously beautiful singing voice is
part of that tradition but ultimately
its own entity depending on who you ask
sirens weren't even all that bad their
songs did drive men to watery graves but
that was only because they were so
skilled at making music and were even
praised for their musical talents to
call someone a siren used to be a
compliment even for the ancient Greeks a
famous rhetorician in the fifth and
fourth century BCE Isocrates
was even buried in a tomb emblazoned
with a siren as a symbol of his
masterful use of language and
exceptional skills in speaking the
original siren myth shows Odysseus
tempted not by how the sirens look but
by what knowledge they offer him
nevertheless the danger associated with
the enchanting song of the creature
increasingly emphasized medieval texts
led to its association with anything
that'll errs or deceives the way we use
the word siren today to refer to
something like a
police siren or emergency alert
originates from an instrument made in
the late 18th century named after the
monster for its ability to produce a
loud sound underwater today we think of
sirens as sexy beautiful women out to
trap and ensnare men ultimately though
sirens are meant to warn us of the
danger of temptation and distractions of
all kinds not all beautiful things are
safe some can even destroy you wow I
don't even know what the freaking aerial
song is wrote in his in I got this I'm
an adult